[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
June 20th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the class of 2023 are entering the
Working World with the skills to do the
day-to-day job but they're lacking
so-called soft skills Wall Street
Journal workplace reporter Lindsay Ellis
joins us so Lindsay what falls under the
category of soft skills many of the
companies that I talked to on this
really described training and
instruction in a few key areas when do
you send an email versus a slack message
versus pop by in person some of it is
what exactly is business casual and when
you can wear denim is all kinds of
deminim okay or is it only certain
Shades or those without rips why are
these skills so important it's one thing
to really Master the technical side of
work the aspect of what it's like to
work in an office and work face to face
that can be not as intuitive for some
people and according to some of the new
graduates I talk to it's a different
skill set and it's a different energy
level than maybe what some of these
people were used to in hybrid
internships or some virtual classes some
in-person classes and the like why are
so many in this year's group of college
grads missing these skills compared to
past graduates see think back to March
2020 when so many college campuses shut
down the folks who graduated from
college in four years they were freshmen
then and just graduating now so the
second half of their freshman year was
disrupted on some campuses they had far
more virtual classes than expected in
their sophomore and Junior years and
instead of in fully in-person internship
it might have been a hybrid internship
or they might have worked for a company
from a distance so they are less
practiced on some of these skills than
their predecessors or potentially the
people coming after them the virtual
classes aspect of this is also really
interesting I was talking to one
Professor who reminded me that on a lot
of virtual classes people had their
cameras off and you can't really tell
when a comment doesn't land in a group
discussion if you can't see other
people's reactions to it and that type
of skill translates to how you work a
room in a meeting or how you kind of
make the rounds at a networking event in
your reporting you mentioned that
schools recruiters and companies are
placing such an emphasis on
interpersonal skills and things like
reading body language why is that partly
it's because it's how you make a first
impression and build a connection face
to face and people are taking different
approaches when they're trying to teach
these skills at Michigan State
University for example their business
school has been requiring for some
students instruction on soft skills and
they've issued a handout saying okay
well when you introduce yourself with
your first and last name pause to give
the other person a chance to introduce
themselves and kind of really getting
down to the details there one HR leader
who I spoke with told me that he gives a
pep talk to new graduates saying it's
okay to feel how you're feeling but make
the round smile introduce yourself stay
check out your hand and that type of
encouragement he says can go a long way
then there's the soft skills that are
more conversational if you're a new
graduate and it's your first time on a
business trip having dinner with a
client what do you talk about around the
table what feels okay what feels like a
little awkward it's that kind of thing
and for the schools and recruiters and
companies providing this training
they're carving out extra time and
resources to do it why do they feel the
need to launch these trainings one
person I talked to at kpng told me that
the team there has noticed that new
grads have been a little stiff and when
they are introducing themselves and in
face-to-face conversations that they've
noticed that there are skills that need
to be built here on the University side
there's an acknowledgment that it
doesn't really matter what's causing
this or whose fault it is it's an effort
to really prepare students to end enter
the world of work and help them build
the skills that they might not have been
prepared for just given their
distinctive college experience every
business wants to make sure that when
they hire new grads and new Talent they
are investing in those individuals to
hopefully stay at the company and work
their way up the ladder so this
certainly is just the beginning of the
pipeline for these new graduates a
moment ago you mentioned training about
what to do at a business dinner what
kinds of things were on the agenda they
trained students on okay don't eat too
quickly follow the pace of some of the
senior leaders at the table that's
actually something I should learn for
myself getting down to like when you
butter a role you know you take a little
bit of butter and you put it on your own
plate before applying it to the role but
some companies are also telling their
early career employees and new graduates
here's what you might wear at a client
site here's what a client-side dinner
might be so there's an instructor action
from both the campus level and also the
company level too how do the grads feel
about breaking away from being in front
of their computers and being in the same
room with business contacts so several
surveys have indicated that new grads
are actually really excited to work face
to face that they want to come into
offices that they want to do this one
survey that we reviewed from timely care
which is a student health company found
that of the members of the class of 2023
that were surveyed far more wanted to
work fully in person than they did to
want fully remote that said some new
graduates I talked to just reminded me
that it takes a different skill set to
show up and work face to face and it's a
level of energy that you bring I mean
you really have to think about what
you're wearing and building in commute
time and all of that is just a different
experience than when you have to open
your laptop and log on to a zoom meeting
that's Wall Street Journal workplace
reporter Lindsay Ellis and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you